Hans how do you feel tonight what's
happening I feel amazing I've been uh on
a sexual tear recently oh tell us about
it is that why you got those pants so we
can't see the all over them
buckets of white drops everywhere I
origin
[Applause]
and this loves it I had a pretty intense
makeout session on Thursday wow are you
11. yeah
I'm just catching up uh what makes it an
intense makeout session
she was willing
[Applause]
she was awake
so this heavy week of sexual activity
and all that we got out of you was an
intense makeout section I had two
intense makeout sessions ooh one
yesterday with a local girl okay
wow that's a vocal girl what does that
mean uh someone from 6th Street like one
of these favorites
he's actually from Deep West
which is a classy neighborhood okay
[Music]